[Music]
nicholas is with us in miami hi nicholas
how are you
how are you
hi there can you hear me absolutely
what's up
yeah you're gonna have to get off your
speaker phone or whatever you're doing
there get back on your regular phone
sorry about that that's right yeah
that's what kelly told you okay how can
we help
so i have a question about inheritance
so basically my dad has a fairly
peculiar relationship with his family
and he has like five siblings slash
nephews that depend on him fully
financially
and i'm my only dad son i'm fully
financially independent however he's
getting kind of old and i want him to
set up a will
to like um divide his state between me
and the people that depend on him
financially but he has not been willing
to do that why so like
basically whenever i bring that topic he
avoids it he tells me that he's gonna do
it sometimes and then he never does it
why
and then
why why does he not do it
i don't know he's just like he doesn't
like to talk about money basically
how much money has he got i think
for like two million in his states
10 million
two million two million
well sometime he used to talk about
money
unless he just fell into a pile of it
somewhere
i mean i think the problem is that
basically he's very
i would say very conservative like
he's very he doesn't want to give out
any information yeah he's cynical
there's
some shame about his siblings he's still
relying on him financially basically
yeah okay right so do you know what his
plan is you i mean does he intend for
the idea does he intend for them to get
the money
i have no idea basically and
uh like everything like he doesn't talk
to me about that
he's holy
he's 77
okay
uh i i hear some kind of accent that's
not southern what what's your accent
what's what's your family heritage i'm
i'm latino latino i'm not your american
and he is as well
yeah okay what country
columbia okay
all right and so he came here with
nothing
yeah and then he he made a significant
amount of money and he's 77 years old
now where do his siblings live are they
back in columbia or are they in the
states they're
they're back in colombia one of them is
in states and the other one fair back in
colombia okay all right
ken i i just want to know if you've ever
actually sat down with him and said uh
pretty plainly
very clearly hey dad you need to do
something about this and see if he's
actually gonna react to you when you do
that or is it just something you're kind
of kicking the can around or all beating
around the bush just curious have you
had a direct re uh responsible
conversation about this
yeah like basically i think around last
year one of my uncles died because of
covet and at that point i'm like okay i
need to have this conversation i sat him
down i told him i want him to make
things clear what will happen with his
money
because i don't want to have that
problem be pushed to me or or to
basically
have to figure out what he wanted to do
once he's dead
he told me that he was going to make a
will and then nothing came out of that
yeah
so do you think
what would be your guess if he did do a
will
that it's gonna say
you think he's gonna want you to manage
this money and take care of his brothers
and sisters
i i think that that i think that's
basically what he actually wants me once
wants to happen do you want to do that
no okay
all right
well the the only thing i know to do is
take another run at it and then you can
just wash your hands of it um and then
another run would sound like this what
where does he live
he's been stuck in colombia at this
point oh he's in colombia as well okay
when will you be with him again do you
think uh probably christmas
okay all right
so um what i would do is say this i i
would go ahead and let's just not have
an abrupt uh conversation where we hit a
wall at christmas but go ahead and start
talking to him by phone now
and just say dad when i'm there
um one of two things is going to occur
while i'm there and i need you to know
this because i love you
uh i want to i want you to help you
uh cause your wishes to be had
and uh you you so when i'm there i want
to see the will or you and i are going
to go meet with the attorney and the
will is going to occur and oh by the way
dad i'm not managing this money for your
siblings so you need to have a different
idea
i'm not willing to do that
i love you i don't need the money
and if you want to do that you can set
it up down there with a trust and so
forth but i'm not going to get sucked
into this where you've done business
poorly and you take up my life and i'm
also not going to get sucked into
managing the money for them for the rest
of my life these are not two things i'm
willing to do dad i love you i'll help
you any other way i can and uh if you
want to be responsible you need to get
your will done and i want to see it when
i'm there at christmas or i'll go with
you when we're there at christmas but it
does not need to say that i'm going to
manage the money for your siblings and
just say all of that on the phone
and just let him kind of get because my
guess is it take probably takes him a
little while to digest it
and uh you you uh grew up in a culture
like i did of honor
hillbillies and latinos share that
okay we're a culture of honor and so you
have to pay him honor
and yet you can honor him and not uh
abide by his wishes
it's possible
but that's just a matter it's just a
matter of telling him that you admire
what he does who he is you admire that
he's taking care of his siblings
i'm not willing to engage in that though
dad and i and i want to honor you upon
your death by making sure that your
wishes occur as long as it doesn't
involve me having to do that and and so
you're being sloppy with this dad and
it's not like you
you're a better businessman than this
and and
and i love you and i admire you so much
you're one of my heroes
that's how you pay honor did you hear it
yeah and that and
am i right that he's a man of honor
yeah i think though
nobody else takes care of their siblings
except people of honor
yeah there's a few that do but they're
just psychos
most people are just he sees that as an
act of honor that's why he does it
yeah
that's who he is as a person
so you need to you can you can
tip your hat to him
pay homage to who he is as a man what a
good person he is and he is a good
person
um and do all of that and yet not fall
into the trap of getting sucked into
managing a an estate with no will
nor get sucked into managing his money
for his brothers and sisters in
perpetuation and you can just lay those
out as boundaries in the discussion and
you can do that while paying him honor
and it's your only shot if he doesn't do
it then you just wash your hands of it
just say dad i just love you but i'm not
doing it i'm not doing nothing when you
die
because i begged you to do this it's all
just going to melt down around their
heads down there
and um
you know you just turn up the heat on it
i don't know ken
no i think it's absolutely right i think
dr john deloney we do yeah or he needs
to read henry cloud's uh uh boundaries i
mean i i think that you nailed it you
just have to put it in his court he
doesn't want to deal with he doesn't
want to talk about it so he kind of acts
like well it's just not there and then
you know honoring him and respecting him
is the way to go but also forcing the
issue yeah yeah you just got to drive
the nail home baby i mean and
i think you were right you're onto
something that
the problem is that the old man's just
being thick
and he's just going it's going to
require a little more direct punch in
the nose to get the thing moving yeah
but the only way to do that is with a
velvet glove it's true so